what should we make of these numbers
from HSBC we will invest X Ian Gordon
joins me now in a let down from Stuart
Gulliver on his last day yes I mean if
we look at the q4 numbers in isolation
they were pretty grim there's a reported
loss after the usual slew of one are
worn off items and on an underlying
basis there was a Miss on every line
against analyst expectations so a Miss
on revenues miss on costs miss on bad
debts miss on associates and potentially
more legacy issues looming potentially
one and a half billion dollar fine at
the Swiss private banking on indeed now
we're not at the end of the road but you
know just to put it in context the
exceptional charge in 2017 was around
four billion in 2016 it's around 12
billion so moving in the right direction
but not yet not there yet and obviously
a lot we are we've heard I mean for the
lights of Goldman Sachs investment
banking revenues damn pretty well across
the piece was HSBC anything actually
ordinary there it's German HSBC normally
outperforms at a weak market and so
there was particular to disappointment
that quarter-on-quarter the underlying
profit from global banking and markets
fell 46 percent or down almost 40
percent year-on-year so it was a
particularly poor performance from that
division which skewed the numbers if I
try and be a bit more positive there
were one or two chinks of light business
year-to-date has improved the margin
stabilized after a decade of decline
customer loans actually grew by seven
percent year-on-year again after a
decade of offer broadly flat performance
except I mean is it's barely increased
revenues in line with course has it yes
and you covered it in the introduction
the return on equity increased a 5.9
percent the target is 10 percent I don't
think that's achievable before 2021 at
the earliest so we saw Stuart Gulliver
there squirming in fronts of the MPs
when they were asking him about his
Panamanian bank account but I mean how
the history books gonna judge him fairly
kindly do you think well he took on a
pretty serious challenge he had some
ambitious targets at the outset back in
2011 which soon became unachievable in
the context of lower for longer interest
rates unanticipated conduct charges and
so here we are what seven years on was
too
we'll talk about a group which has been
repositioned as strong capital strong
liquidity but very weak earnings yeah I
mean once upon a time HSBC quarter not
that long ago really HSBC called itself
the world's local bank I mean that
basically it's back to being a big bank
in Asia with arms in the UK the US and
and a few other bits and pieces in
between I mean that's maybe a little bit
unkind about babban directionally you're
right yeah over the course of the last
six seven years they've closed around 80
businesses or withdrawn from geographies
which either fail to meet group return
targets or have other issues such as
conduct as you can you alluded to an
introduction yeah so what can we expect
from John Flint the new CEO well I think
directionally it's more of the same as I
say they're trying to be a bit more
constructive there are some things which
are finally moving the right direction
but yet we are still talking about an
organization after all that reshaping
which still has a cost income ratio on
an underlying basis in excess of 60
percent revenue growth is challenging
its main growth market in Hong Kong and
Asia is seeing significant competitive
pressure so pressure on margins you know
I'm calling out stabilizing margins as a
positive but the group margin is half
where it was in 2005 briefly and we've
got all the other big banks reporting
later this week I mean HSBC such a
global bank there's not much of a reader
cross to the other banks easily it's
pretty limited I mean there's a sort of
quirk of history Lloyds now has it
within its gift to eclipse HSBC is the
biggest yielding Bank it could deliver
that tomorrow if it doesn't tomorrow it
will do any year's time all right fall
it fall to that you ain't got them from
invest at good to see you thank you